[Musique]
bien sujet évidemment et puis ensuite en
battant petit peu plus sérieux parce que
c'est un sujet qui est évidemment
beaucoup moins drôle et pour lui et pour
les autres pas pour tout le monde je
pense surtout vivent plus de victimes
qu'à lui mais christian quesada et sa
vie en prison la semaine dernière s'est
vue de proposer un documentaire c'est un
véritable carton on y apprenait que
l'ancien maître des coups de midi
suivrait actuellement un enfer en prison
on va regarder tout de suite le
témoignage de l'un de ses codétenus et
puis ensuite on va avoir des
informations sur voie là où il est
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe pour lui
qu'elle est venir éventuellement pour
christian quesada c'est vraiment ce
qu'on appelle une descente aux enfers
regarder à la prison de bourg-en-bresse
quesada et placé à l'isolément à l'écart
des autres détenus
et c'est sans doute mieux pour sa
sécurité mais alors combien de temps
christian quesada va-t-il rester en
détention provisoire
on peut même imaginer que c'est
quelqu'un qui est profondément détruit
il a gagné beaucoup d'argent même été
fortement médiatisée et
il n'est plus rien actuellement et on
peut craindre pour sa fragilité
psychologique
oui voilà donc effectivement rappelle
qu'il est détenu à la prison de bourg en
bresse depuis plus d'un mois et demi
maintenant il est placé en isolement
c'est là où on met vraiment j'ai les
gens notamment quand il ya des histoires
un peu et protéger ils étaient nos sorts
à pour les protéger des autres détenus
c'est une des prisons les plus violentes
de france il serait totalement déprimé
il prendrait un traitement pour dormir
toute la journée
enfin c'est vraiment une descente aux
enfers est-ce que vous avez des infos
vous qui êtes toujours bien et fort bien
informée sébastien les infos c'est un
peu ce que ce que disait le codétenu il
y a deux problèmes qui se posent pour
lui dans ce genre de situation être en
prison c'est que d'abord il est connu
mais il est on va dire conditionnelle
accusé de crimes plus ou moins et
pédophile ou violent enfin bon il est
présumé innocent mais c'est un peu la
sexuelle a donc d'aix a su il est
considéré comme un pointeur par les
prisonniers voilà c'est simple pointeur
bywater s'essayer au viol tous les pays
qui sont très mal vus du 2d autres
codétenus donc pour sa sécurité lui sont
obligés de l'isoler est il réellement en
danger à mon avis il est pas isolé mais
psychologiquement donc il est il
rappelle qu'il est en prison
c'est ce qu'estiment les la firme aux
détenus donc donc voilà donc il est en
danger donc automatiquement on le met
seul dans son coin ça veut dire qu'il
est seul 23 heures par jour et même je
pense que pendant la promenade il est
seul ça serait beaucoup trop dangereux
quand il sort il se fait insulter
même quand ils sont passés ils sont pas
à proximité mais quand ils savent qu'il
est dans les couloirs en pro nature il
se fait insulter
donc il est aussi sous médicaments parce
que ça doit être très difficile mais
d'un autre côté l'administration
pénitentiaire peut elle aussi craindre
un suisse un suicide donc voilà tout ça
est très touchy et il peut rester
jusqu'au procès ça peut durer c'est
toujours étonnant quand présent fait les
on n'imagine pas que les détenus se
jugent entre eux mais il est presque un
classement de l'agof et cela l'a
toujours qui leur est pédophile
cela sape respect rappelle encore une
fois que c'est pas ce dont il est accusé
un bien normal est-ce que quelqu'un sait
s'il a droit à des visites mais la
droite dans le cul parce qu tu as on ne
l'est pas condamner ces instructions
pour l'instant cela va faire donc il
n'est pas encore condamné il a forcément
droit de visite
après il est pas hyper hyper proches
minutes son ex-femme évidemment
ces enfants c'est pas si facile non plus
donc c'est pas sait pas non plus qui
dope est pas facile comme comme contexte
quoi bon aller le visiter mais c'est
vrai que de toutes les façons dans les
prisons les gens qui sont dans la sphère
de la pédophilie qui sont pour que lui
c'est détention d'image mais c'est donc
ce n'est pas du tout du viol mais pour
le coup bien sûr s'il n'est pas passé à
l'acte pour les gens iraient les
célèbres en prusse
ils savent qu'ils la gagnent de l'argent
et ça même la somme et en plus voilà il
a dans la sphère pédophiles donc
forcément c'est ça s'il va servir s'il
était dans les douches avec les autres
ou ce qu'il était même dans la cour etc
c'est sûr qu'il souhaitait que péter les
dents en deux ans deux secondes quoi ce
qui évidemment se dit beaucoup aussi et
c'est horrible c'est qu'elle est vraie
braderie c'est pour ça qu'il est
surveillée de deux tentatives de suicide
aussi je sais pas ce que vous vous
retrouvez notamment des infos données
pour les magazines people est ce que
vous osez les on va dire la vérité est
ce que vous osez les publié par armelle
jamais rien sur la prison de
bourg-en-bresse parce que j'avais des
infos pour nabila en prison à l'époque
fait des photos tout ça et c'est que des
terroristes est plus léger oui l'été la
boillat m qui était venu déposer des
serbes je suis comme un bien pâle avait
bien non mais bon au final alors voilà
mais cédric alors qu'on savait qu'elle
faisait des cours allaient passer son
brevet des collèges tout ça parce qu'on
a vu des infos mais c'était plus léger
la présente élection alger où elle a
passé son brevet en banque il est à
peine au brevet des collèges
elle n'avait pas eu la populaire elle
pour le coup mais lui en a pas d'image
pourquoi vous n'avez pas d'image
pascal y aura quelques jours est ce que
voulait publier meriam si vous en aviez
si vous aviez des infos ou des images
chez n'importe quoi une image qui a été
prise par un drone de lui de lui c'est
compliqué il ya des prisons c'est
jouable à la page web c'est impossible
d'avoir une raison vous l'avez déjà fait
il ya des prisons où c'est possible
voilà il y en a d'autres non celle là
c'est vraiment une des plus dures plus
dur plus dur plus dur vous n'êtes pas
contacté par les prisonniers vous n'avez
ya pas d des matons ou que vous n'ayez
pas de messe à des infos de chacun sur
cette histoire
on a vraiment non mais le fait que ce
soit les allemands fait qu'ils vont être
pris en photo match aller au paraguay
restera donc c'est compliqué pour faire
sortir des infos ou est ce que c'est un
hasard qui sont imposantes
bourg-en-bresse qu'est conseillé
pourquoi elle est considérée comme l'une
des plus violentes se séparent mais je
pense que ça c'est juridique
utilisation catherine vous avez des
infos vous pas dit tout bas
alors leur moi c'est vraiment vrai mais
risquant même sept ans de prison pour
les faits et deux ans pour l'autre plus
la plainte qui a été sorti d'on parisien
en début de semaine le potentiel violent
d'une majeure cette fois il va peut-être
rester en prison longtemps le cam la
question à elle est honnête si jamais
vous aviez la possibilité d'avoir des
infos ou des photos ou une photo de lui
d'abord est-ce que vous là vous essayer
de la vendre
oui pourquoi pas il a tué ya pas deux et
vous publier quelque chose si vous avez
une photo des furieux une non pas là
enfin pas la une sur public non mais sur
wii sur 5 aux heures si la photo est
parlante il ya quelque chose qui se
passe ces enfants qui viennent le voir
s'il ya quelque chose à l histoire et la
photo est bonne elle seule a fait la une
ce problème parce que question que sanaa
était quand même c'était qu'à l'image de
la france mais aussi par un jeu et que
ça qu'ils se sauvent 3 sur ces huit
kevin jarre et envoyée aux chiffres et
aux lettres en fait quand il était une
des stars des chiffres des chiffres est
laide j'étais assistante et je me
souviens que c'était la petite star de
l'émission
et moi je n'ai jamais entendu parler de
rien à ce moment là il faisait des
tournois les prime et ça et j'ai jamais
entendu parler c'est vraiment grandeur
et de la mêlée l'argentine c'est comme
quand on fait le micro-trottoir sa
voiture
non mais une bêtise c'est con mais c'est
toujours dit si un jour je fais une
bêtise
j'ai toujours dit qu'est ce que diraient
les voisins surnom de l'imam gibbons
jours à personne c'est pas la fête des
voisins médias la reine copropriété
bon ben je fais la gueule on serre je
pense qu'il dirait on s'en doute
dans les couloirs on dirait la même
chose même évidemment mais pourquoi
alors la vie des gens n'est jamais dans
la chambre des gens on n'est jamais dans
la maison des gens dont on ne connaît
pas tous les sens